what you really want is to  create a setup where it's easy to do the  things that pay off in the long run and  you have the mentality of i'm the type  person who will work hard so imagine you  have a hose that's like bent in the  middle and there's a little bit of water  trickling out if you want to get more  water through the hose then you have two  options the first is you could just  crank up the valve and force water  through  but that increases friction and  increases tension in the the system  the other option is just to unfold the  bend and let the water flow through  naturally and that also gets more water  to flow through but it reduces tension  and reduces friction so much of the  conversation about building better  habits and achieving peak performance is  all the mental equivalent of cranking up  the valve you need to work harder you  need to have grit persevere hustle grind  and it's not that those qualities are  bad it's just that it increases tension  in the system